WE NEED THE DOCUMENTS RELEASED.
THEY'RE DEMANDING TO SEE IT.
A LOT TO COVER.
TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
WE START WITH ANOTHER STINGING
SETBACK FOR THE SPECIAL COUNSEL,
ROBERT MUELLER.
RUDY GULIANI IS SAYING TONIGHT
THAT ROBERT MUELLER WILL NOT
SEEK A PRESIDENTIAL INDICT.
IT'S OBVIOUS WHY MUELLER WON'T
EVEN TRY BECAUSE AS WE HAVE BEEN
TELLING YOU, HE NEVER HAD A
LEGAL LEG TO STAND ON.
DOJ GUIDELINES CLEARLY STATE
THAT A SITTING PRESIDENT CANNOT
BE INDICTED.
NOT TO MENTION MUELLER DOESN'T
HAVE A REASON TO DO SO IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
MUELLER HAS ZERO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION, HAS ONLY BEEN FOCUSED
ON THE VAULT CRIMES OF THE
PRESIDENT AND IT'S NOT A CRIME
TO HAVE THOUGHTS.
RUDY GULIANI REACTING TO
TOMORROW BEING THE ONE-YEAR
ANNIVERSARY OF MUELLER'S CORRUPT
INVESTIGATION.
HERE'S PART OF THE INTERVIEW
THAT WILL AIR WITH LAURA.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> WHAT IS THE TIMELINE FOR THIS
TO WRAP UP?
>> THEY SHOULD DO IT TODAY.
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
THAT I HAVE THE FACTS TO WRITE
THEIR REPORT.
YOU CAN WRITE A FAIR REPORT,
FINE.
IF YOU CAN WRITE AN UNFAIR
REPORT, WRITE IT AROUND WE'LL
COMBAT IT.
WE'RE READY.
>> THE FORMER NEW YORK CITY
MAYOR IS RIGHT ABOUT THIS.
HE TOLD LAURA INGRAHAM ABOUT THE
DAMAGE THAT THIS INVESTIGATION
IS DOING TO THIS COUNTRY.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FLASH
POINTS, THE TRUMP TOWER MEETING,
THE STORMY DANIELS PAYMENT, THE
RAID ON MANAFORT, THE RAIN ON
COHEN, IS THERE ONE PART OF THAT
THAT CONCERNS THE OTHER PARTS?
>> YEAH, THEIR INABILITY TO
REACH A CONCLUSION THAT IS
OBVIOUS AND INWILLINGNESS TO
RECOGNIZE THE DAMAGE THIS DOES
TO OUR COUNTRY.
THIS WAS ENGINEERED BY COMEY.
>> Sean: WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THIS
WITH JOE AND LAURA'S FILL
INTERVIEW WITH RUDY THAT AIRS
AFTER THIS PROGRAM.
ON THE FOREIGN POLICY FRONT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT BLINKING
IN THE STANDOFF WITH KIM JONG-UN
AND NORTH KOREA.
REMEMBER, KIM JONG-UN IS NOW
TRYING TO ACT TOUGH AS HE EGO
HAS BEEN BRUISED.
HE'S THREATENING TO WITHDRAW
FROM THE SUMMIT.
HE SAID DENUCLEARIZATION IS NOT
ON THE TABLE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HIS PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH POLICY
CONTINUES.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'LL HAVE TO SAY.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WHATEVER IT IS --
>> Sean: OBVIOUSLY THE LIBERAL
MEDIA IN A FRENZY OVER THIS
DEVELOPMENT.
THINK ABOUT IT, FOR THEM TO
SUCCEED AND THE PRESIDENT TO
FAIL.
FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO SUCCEED IS
THE PRESIDENT TO FAIL.
THE PRESIDENT IS STANDING FIRM
ON DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
JOHN BOLTON SAYS THIS IS PART OF
THE GAME THAT NORTH KOREA ALWAYS
PLAYS.
UNLIKE CLINTON, WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO BRIBE THE GUY.
>> THE QUESTION IS IF THIS IS
REALLY A SIGN THIS THEY'RE NOT
TAKING DENUCLEARIZATION
SERIOUSLY.
KIM JONG-UN TOLD SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT AT THE APRIL 27 SUMMIT
THAT HE AGREED TO
DENUCLEARIZATION.
SO IF THEY'RE WALKING BACK FROM
IT, WE'LL FIND OUT.
SARAH SANDERS SAID THIS MORNING
PRETTY MUCH WHAT THE PRESIDENT
IS THINKING.
IF THEY'RE READY TO MEET, WE'RE
READY TO MEET.
IF THEY'RE NOT READY, THEN WE
WON'T MEET.
>> Sean: WE HAVE THE THREE
HOSTAGES BACK.
HE'S NOT FIRING MISSILES, SO FAR
A WIN.
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE, TRUST
BUT VERIFY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT GIVING UP
ANYTHING.
KIM JONG-UN HAS MADE EVERY
CONCESSION, HE GAVE UP THE
HOSTAGES.
WE DON'T HAVE TO APPEASE HIM
WITH A PLANE LOAD OF CASH AND
CURRENCIES AND $150 BILLION LIKE
OBAMA DID WITH IRAN.
SO THE BALL IS IN KIM JONG-UN'S
COURT.
HE WANTS TO TALK, HE WANTS A
DEAL, HE WANTS A BETTER LIFE FOR
HIS PEOPLE, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
READY TO LISTEN.
NORTH KOREA WON'T BE ALLOWED TO
BUILD NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THAT'S A FACT.
THE.
HAS MADE IT CRYSTAL CLEAR.
WE'RE GETTING CLARITY ON ANOTHER
MAJOR STORY.
REMEMBER HOW THE PAST YEAR THE
LEFT WING MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS
PROMISING THAT TRUMP TOWER
MEETING WAS SOMEHOW THE BIG
SMOKING GUN OF RUSSIA COLLUSION?
TONIGHT IN SPEED OF MEDIA
REPORTS, WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE
THAT IT WAS A TOTAL DUD.
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
RELEASED THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF
TESTIMONY.
SEVERAL KEY PLAYERS AT THE
MEETING.
THE MAKE TAKE-AWAY IS THIS.
THEY ALL THOUGHT IT WAS A WASTE
OF THEIR TIME.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
ADOPTION.
NO DIRT ON HILLARY CLINTON CAME
THROUGH.
IF IT DID, IT WOULDN'T BE
ILLEGAL.
WE'LL EXPLAIN THAT TONIGHT.
FROM ALL ACCOUNTS, THIS MEETING
WENT OFF THE RAILS AND FOCUSSED
IN ON TOPICS LIKE RUSSIAN
ADOPTION AND RUSSIAN ADOPTION.
IT'S A NOTHING BURGER.
THE MEDIA HAVE BEEN HYPING THIS
AS A CRUISE MISSILE THAT WAS
GOING TO TAKE DOWN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
DONALD TRUMP JR., HE TESTIFIED.
HE WAS SKEPTICAL GOING INTO THE
MEETING AND THAT HIS SUSPICIONS
WERE QUICKLY JUSTIFIED.
DONALD TRUMP JR. ALSO SAID THAT
HIS FATHER, PRESIDENT TRUMP, HAD
NOTHING AT ALL TO DO WITH IT IN
ANY WAY, SHAPE OR FORM.
DESPITE ALL OF THIS WILD AND
FALSE SPECULATION, IT'S NOTHING.
THE TRUMP TOWER MEETING IS NOT
THE ONLY BREAKING NEWS STORY
THAT IS EMBARRASSING TO THE
DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THEY HATE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY'RE NOW BASICALLY TONIGHT
CONFIRMING EVERYTHING WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU REGARDING THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT A MAYA CULPA, IT'S
PROBABLY INADVERTENT.
THIS WAS THEIR ORIGINAL HEADLINE
TODAY.
A SECRET MISSION, A CODE NAME
AND ANXIETY INSIDE THE EARLY
DAYS OF THE FBI'S TRUMP
INVESTIGATION.
THEY CHANGED THE HEADLINE.
CODE NAME CROSSFIRE HURRICANE.
THE SECRET ORIGINS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
GREAT TO KNOW SOMEBODY IN THE
FBI LIKE THE ROLLING STONES.
WHY WOULD THEY CHANGE IT?
LET ME EXPLAIN.
IT'S A LONG ARTICLE.
THE TIMES EXPLAINS HOW THE FBI
OPENED A TOP SECRET OPERATION
INTO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
BY THE WAY, ONLY DAYS AFTER THEY
RIGGED THE INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY AND THE SAME EXACT
PLAYERS.
NOW, THE DETAILS WERE CLOSELY
GUARDED BY FBI OFFICIALS.
THIS ALL HAPPENED DAYS JUST DAYS
AFTER THE SAME PEOPLE PUT THE
FIX IN WITH THE EXONERATION OF
HILLARY CLINTON, RIGGING IT
AND OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
EVERYTHING WE'VE BEEN EXPOSING.
TO BREAK IT DOWN THIS WAY, IN
THE SUMMER OF 2016, THEY
INTERVIEWED ALEXANDER DOWNER.
HE'S THE GUY THAT GOT DRUNK ONE
NIGHT WITH SOME GUY.
I THOUGHT I KNEW EVERYBODY IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
NEVER HEARD OF HIM.
THE TRUMP ADVISER THAT HEARD OF.
WHILE DRINKING, THEY GOSSIPED
LIKE MEAN GIRLS AND DIRT ON
HILLARY CLINTON.
DOWNER ALERTED THE AUSTRALIAN
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY THAT TOLD
THEIR U.S. COUNTER PARTS.
FOUR-WAY HEARSAY.
THIS IS MASSIVE.
THE TIMES IS CONFIRMING THAT THE
FBI USED FOUR-WAY HEARSAY TO
LAUNCH AN INVESTIGATION LIKE
WE'VE BEEN TELLING YOU ON THE
PROGRAM.
THEIR TIMELINE DOESN'T MATCH UP
AND HEARSAY IS NEVER ADMISSIBLE
NEVER MIND FOUR-WAY HEARSAY IN A
COURT OF LAW.
SO WHAT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
PROVING IS WE'VE BEEN RIGHT THE
ENTIRE TIME AND IN THE PROCESS
OF TRYING TO COVER UP FOR THEIR
DEEP STATE FRIENDS AND MAKING
EXCUSES, THEY'RE EXPOSING THEM.
THE TIMES AND THE REST OF THE
MEDIA HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET
AHEAD OF WHAT IS A MASSIVE
SCANDAL AND PROTECT THE LIKES OF
COMEY AND SOMEBODY CAKE AND
STRZOK AND LYNCH AND PAGE AND
EVERYONE ELSE.
BUT THEY CAN'T BECAUSE THE
FACTS, THE EVIDENCE, THE TRUTH
IS FINALLY COMING OUT.
WE HAVE BEEN PROMISING YOU THIS.
SO FAR WHAT WE'VE BEEN
UNCOVERING IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING.
THIS IS GOING TO GET WORSE FOR
ALL OF THESE DEEP STATE ACTORS
BEFORE IT GETS BETTER.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE SIDE OF YOUR
SCREEN.
JAMES COMEY, ANDREW McCABE,
LORETTA LYNCH, PETER STRZOK,
LISA PAGE, ALL AT THE CENTER OF
THIS SCANDAL.
COMEY IS A LIAR AND LEAKER.
McCABE LIED UNDER OATH MULTIPLE
TIMES.
LORETTA LYNCH TRIED TO
COMPROMISE THE CLINTON E-MAIL
INVESTIGATION AND COMEY TO SAY
IT'S NOTICE AN INVESTIGATION.
IT'S ONLY A MATTER.
THEN YOU HAVE THE FBI ANTI-TRUMP
LOVEBIRDS, STRZOK AND PAGE.
THEY ABUSED THE PRESIDENT
VERBALLY, ATTACKING HIM IN
TEXTS.
AND STRZOK'S FINGERPRINTS ARE
ALL OVER EVERYTHING.
MORE ON THAT IN A SECOND.
ANOTHER BIG STORY FIRST TO TELL
YOU ABOUT.
THE DOJ'S ATTEMPT TO SLOW WALK,
STONE WALL, OBSTRUCT CONGRESS
FROM EVER SEEING OVER 1.2
MILLION DOCUMENTS ABOUT THE
CLINTON E-MAIL SERVER
INVESTIGATION AND THE RUSSIA
WITCH HUNT, WHICH SHOULD BE
COMING TO AN END.
THEY'RE NOW ASKING THE PRESIDENT
TO USE HIS EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY
AND INSTRUCT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, JEFF SESSIONS WHO
SHOULD BE DOING IT ON HIS OWN TO
IMMEDIATELY TURN OVER ALL
DOCUMENTS THAT CONGRESS HAS
SUBPOENAED AND HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT CO-EQUAL
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT AND A
RIGHT TO OVERSIGHT AND
SEPARATION OF POWERS.
IT'S UNSANE.
IT'S UNFAIR TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THAT IT HAS COME TO THIS
AS CONGRESS HAS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY AS PART
OF THEIR CHECKS AND BALANCES.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, HE'S BEEN
CONCEALING INFORMATION AND THEN
NEEDLESSLY REDACTING KEY PARTS
OF THESE THINGS IN THE NAME OF
NATIONAL SECURITY THAT GETS
PROVEN LATER NOT TO HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH NATIONAL
SECURITY.
ROSENSTEIN CLAIMS THAT, BUT IT'S
NOT TRUE.
WE'VE SEEN THIS LIE PLAY OUT.
IT'S ABOUT PROTECTING ALL OF HIS
FRIENDS.
MEANWHILE, HE'S CONFLICTED FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING OF THIS.
BY THE WAY, WAS A NO-SHOW FOR A
CLOSED DOOR HEARING WITH THE
SENATE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
I WONDER WHY.
SEVERAL OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS, THEY WERE QUOTED BUT
COMEY DODGED THE ENTIRE THING.
THAT'S TELLING.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN AND DESANTIS
WILL JOIN US IN A MINUTE, A
MAJOR FOLLOW UP ON THE FORMER
OBAMA OFFICIAL THAT AT ONE POINT
VOTED FOR THE COMMUNIST FOR
PRESIDENT.
HOW HE BECAME A CIA DIRECTOR IS
BREATHTAKING.
JONATHAN BRENNAN.
PAUL SPERRY REPORTEDLY
THREATENED THE PRESIDENT AND IS
NOW BEING EXPOSED BY A LIAR.
LAST MAY THE FORMER CIA DIRECTOR
TESTIFIED UNDER OATH THAT THE
DOSSIER DIDN'T FACTOR INTO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY'S
ASSESSMENT OF RUSSIA ELECTION
MEDDLING.
WE HAVE THE TAPE TO PROVE IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU KNOW IN THE BUREAU RELIED
ON THE STEELE DOSSIER AS PART OF
ANY COURT FILINGS?
APPLICATIONS, PETITIONS,
PLEADINGS?
>> I HAVE NO AWARENESS.
>> DID THE CIA RELY ON IT?
>> NO.
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE WE -- IT WASN'T PART
OF THE CORPUS OF INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAD.
IT WAS NOT IN ANY WAY USED AS A
BASIS FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY ASSESSMENT THAT WAS
DONE.
IT WAS NOT.
>> Sean: MIKE ROGERS AND JAMES
CLAPPER ARE CONTRADICTING
BRENNAN AND SAYING THAT YES, THE
DOSSIER DID PLAY A ROLE IN TO
WHAT AMERICAN INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES CONCLUDED.
JUST LIKE THE GRASSLEY GRAND
MEMO.
ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT, BRENNAN
HAND PICKED PETER STRZOK TO HELP
WORK ON THIS REPORT.
THE SAME GUY THAT PUT THE FIX IN
FOR HILLARY AND THE SAME GUY
THAT TRASHED PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
TEXT AFTER TEXT AND THEN FEW
DAYS AFTER EXONERATING AND
RIGGING THE HILLARY
INVESTIGATION LAUNCHES AN
INVESTIGATION INTO DONALD TRUMP.
THIS DEEP STATE IS ONE HUGE
GIANT INCESTUOUS, CORRUPT SWAMP.
THE MORE WE LEARN THAT PETER